Ontario's top doctor is warning that
mask mandates could return if coveted
cases continue to climb and further
jeopardize the Health Care System chief
medical officer of Health Dr Kieran
Moore says he has not yet made that
official recommendation but he could if
the situation in the province worsens
the Ontario government also announcing
today that those 12 years and older can
now get the bivalent covid-19 booster
shot the eligibility will officially
expand on October 17th for Pfizer's shot
targeting Omicron sub-variants which are
currently dominating strains the
currently the dominant strains that are
circulating pardon me Dr Moore is urging
ontarians to stay updated on their
vaccinations and to wear a mask in order
to help relieve pressure on hospitals
my recommendation is anyone at risk to
this virus influenza and or covid please
mask in public spaces right now as
you're going indoors and Subways Transit
malls box stores please mask we have to
cut the rate of transmission and at the
same time my call is to come forward the
bivalent vaccine is excellent both
products are excellent at protecting
against Omicron strains we are so
fortunate to have them in Ontario
accessible and available and free and
your pharmacist your physician your
health unit is waiting for you to come
forward to get vaccinated there's plenty
of space and capacity to vaccinate the
bookings are available now for the 17.